gemüse und frisches zu jeder jahreszeit
am liebsten günstig doch wer zahlt den
wahren preis
wir sind keine tiere
wir sind menschen zig-tausende ernten in
spanien was in deutschland auf dem tisch
kommt wie sie arbeiten und wie sie leben
wissen die meisten nicht
die haben früchte und gemüse gefüllt und
dann kam ein typ und hat mir staub ins
gesicht getreten
hungerlöhne ausbeutung nicht selten
bitterer armut die bundesregierung hat
versprochen das zu ändern
wer global gewinne macht muss auch
global verantwortung für menschenrechte
tragen
[Musik]
anfang märz
wir sind unterwegs in südspanien immer
wieder haben wir geschichten gehört über
miese arbeitsbedingungen und nicht
bezahlte löhne ausbeutung die gemüse
industrie soll menschen als
arbeitssklaven missbrauchen es soll
sogar tote gegeben haben was ist dran an
diesen vorwürfen
und wer trägt die verantwortung wir sind
nur wenige kilometer von der
küstenautobahn entfernt dort liegt das
land harras hier leben tausende
migranten den selbst gebauten zelten und
hütten
die meisten von ihnen illegal sie
stammen aus afrika wir treffen männer
aus ghana arbeitet seit drei jahren als
erntehelfer in spanien
some people
es gibt leute die dir vielleicht vier
euro 50 für eine stunde bezahlen vier
euro 50 das ist hier der preis
du kannst dich nicht beschweren weil du
keine dokumente hast das ist es was ich
sage wenn du keine papiere hast hast du
keine stimme wenn du dich beschwert und
keine dokumente hast dann werfen sie
sich einfach raus und nehmen einen
anderen migranten wer hier lebt kennt
auch die geschichte eines erntehelfer
aus nicaragua der bei brütender hitze
wassermelonen pflücken musste sein name
landon im august 2020 erlitt er einen
hitzschlag und starb wie konnte es dazu
kommen
wir treffen die schwester des toten an
ab london
gemeinsam wollen wir zur plantage auf
der ihr bruder gestorben ist
erst hierher gekommen um zu arbeiten und
zwar für seine kinder daran hat er immer
gedacht seinen kindern eine bessere
zukunft zu bereiten immer das beste zu
geben für seine kinder kurz vor seinem
tod hatte er seiner schwester ein foto
geschickt es zeigt ihn bei der ernte im
hintergrund eine bergkette
wir finden das fällt heute wächst hier
kopfsalat
ihr bruder habe immer wieder erzählt
unter welchen schikanen erarbeiten
musste
[Musik]
hier an dieser stelle hin mein bruder
also gebückt am boden
so hat es mir erzählt wie daham früchte
und gemüse gepflückt und dann kam ein
typ und hat mir staub ins gesicht
getreten
ich stelle mir das jetzt so vor wie der
lang gegangen ist und das getan hat
mein gott er hat gesagt anna ich dränge
mich so an so viele wassermelonen wie
möglich zu pflücken aber egal wie sehr
du dich an strengste nie ist es genug
immer heißt es du bist ein nichtsnutz du
bist zu langsam
du bist ein esel selbst wenn du dich tot
arbeit ist und völlig erschöpft nach
hause kommst du hast du dein job gut
gemacht
[Musik]
die schwester hatte gehofft an der
plantage einen der chefs anzutreffen
aber niemand ist da
sie hat viele fragen warum hat man ihnen
nicht geholfen
es ist doch so heiß hier man hätte ihm
doch irgendetwas anbieten können und
warum hat mich niemand angerufen und mir
gesagt was passiert ist geburt die
amboss los einer erklärung warum
seit dem tod aller saß im august 2020
laufen ermittlungen gegen einen
arbeitsvermittler den besitzer der
plantage lassen die behörden in ruhe
warum
wer ist der mann
wir bekommen heraus der gemüseproduzent
besitzt mehrere firmen die auch nach
deutschland exportieren
angeblich hat er beste drähte in die
politik
wir rufen ihn an wollen ihn treffen kein
problem sagt er wir sollten einfach
zurück zur plantage kommen eine halbe
stunde später
wir halten ausschau doch der mann taucht
nicht auf
plötzlich eine whatsapp nachricht der
unternehmer sagt ab und schreibt wir
sollten mit seinem anwalt reden wir
rufen noch einmal in der firma anfragen
nach den wassermelonen dem toten
erntehelfer aus nicaragua und der
verantwortung der firma kein interview
später teilt die firma auf schriftliche
nachfrage mit zitat wir möchten den
keiner tv-sendung erscheinen mit
freundlichen grüßen
wir fahren in die kleinstadt marathon
dort sind wir mit dem regionalchef der
arbeitergewerkschaft verabredet wir
wollen mit ihm über den fall einer saab
london reden
jedes jahr kommt es vor dass ihr
arbeiter sterben
es trifft vor allem erntehelfer und
bauarbeiter das sind die die am meisten
betroffen sind die produzenten kümmere
dass wenig die hätten schlicht ihren
profit im blick für bessere preise
schließen sich die unternehmer zusammen
zuerst produzieren sie jeder für sich
dann exportieren sie gemeinsam der
gewerkschaftschef bekommt besuch
drei marokkanischer männer ohne papiere
bitten ihn um hilfe
sie erzählen am tag zuvor habe ihr chef
sie von der tomaten plantage verjagt
erntehelfer ohne aufenthaltspapiere
seien besonders schutzlos sagt der
gewerkschafter zur entlassung hat man
ihnen gesagt deine arbeit ist hiermit
beendet du scheiß marokkaner
rassistische beleidigungen das ist hier
ziemlich normal
vor allem in kleinen unternehmen und
dazu kommen noch andere delikte wie
sexuelle übergriffe da bleibt es dann
nicht mehr bei der ausbeutung der
arbeitskraft die chefs missbrauchen ihre
macht wir haben viele fälle zur anzeige
gebracht im aktuellen fall seien
hungerlöhne gezahlt worden
die firmen haben keine skrupel
es gibt den mindestlohn 7 eur 32 pro
stunde
aber diese firma hat nur fünf euro pro
stunde bezahlt und sie mussten von
montag bis sonntag arbeiten
wir fahren zu der plantage wollen mit
dem firmenchef sprechen und treffen auf
dessen vater
[Musik]
wir zeigen ihm die strafanzeige der
marokkaner der eine hat hier zwei jahre
und elf monate gearbeitet einen monat
bevor er einen arbeitsvertrag hätte
bekommen können haben sie ihn entlassen
er hat keine papiere er war illegal in
spanien und hätte jetzt den vertrag
bekommen können und sie haben ihn
einfach rausgeworfen
[Musik]
der mann tut verdutzt sagt es sei ja nur
der eine entlassen worden der andere
habe pflanzen kaputt gemacht im wert von
30.000 euro
ich habe ihm gesagt er soll nicht mehr
kommen solange die sache nicht
aufgearbeitet ist
arbeitnehmerrechte bei dieser firma
offenbar fehlanzeige
ein anderer gemüseproduzent aus der
region wirbt mit solchen bildern
glückliche menschen und saftige tomaten
die firma beschäftigt 2400 arbeiter
80.000 tonnen gemüse werden jährlich
produziert 90 prozent davon gehen ins
ausland
wir treffen manuell navarro lopez der
spanier beschwerte sich zahlreiche male
über miserable arbeitsbedingungen bei
der firmenleitung schaltete sogar die
behörden ein
daraufhin kündigte ihm die firma
[Musik]
ich arbeite hier alles und dann sagen
sie mir das um 4 die personalchefin
kommt und dann kommt die und sagt zu mir
warum denn das frage ich krank war
warum werfen die mich raus weil ich
meine arbeit gemacht habe ich habe zur
personalchefin gesagt ich habe familie
ich habe eine frau und eine tochter ich
muss sie ernähren aber sie sagt nur das
habe die firma so entschieden
[Musik]
lopez zog vor gericht und gewann im
urteil von mitte februar heißt es dass
boni sah ihn wieder einstellen muss dazu
10.000 euro schadensersatz
wir sind keine tiere wir sind menschen
wir fragen nach bei der gemüse firma in
einer schriftlichen stellungnahme teilte
nissan mit zitat wir sind mit diesem
urteil nicht einverstanden und werden
dagegen in berufung gehen mit dem ziel
dass alle 2400 mitarbeiter von brunis
die gleichen rechte und pflichten haben
obst und gemüse unter miserablen
bedingungen in spanien geerntet verkauft
in deutschland
wir bitten die großen deutschen
lebensmittelhändler die mit bonita
zusammenarbeiten um stellungnahmen
kaum einer will sich konkret zu unseren
recherchen äußern
nur aldi süd teil schließlich mit das
unternehmen werde die geschilderten
verstöße untersuchen und was macht die
politik
wir treffen frank schwabe den
menschenrechtspolitische sprecher der
spd fraktion im bundestag und wir zeigen
ihm unsere aufnahmen
[Musik]
absolut inakzeptable unhaltbare zustände
und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher wenn die
menschen an der gemüse und obst theke in
deutschland wissen würden unter welchen
bedingungen dieses obst und gemüse
produziert wird dann wenn sie das
bestimmt nicht gut
doch kann der verbraucher an der theke
wirklich etwas tun gegen die ausbeutung
die politik hat reagiert im februar
beschloss die bundesregierung das
sogenannte lieferketten gesetz mit dem
deutsche supermärkte in die pflicht
genommen werden sollen
wer global in einer globalisierten
wirtschaft gewinne macht muss auch
global verantwortung für menschenrechte
tragen
das gesetz hat also zähne und es wird
wirken teils parteifreund schwabe mag
daran nicht so recht glauben
es geht nicht genug in die tiefe der die
ursprüngliche idee die spd hatte war
dass alle vorprodukte unter sorgfältigen
standards produziert werden müssen
und da die union eben eine verbesserung
eingebracht so dass für mich heute nicht
genau klar ist ob das gesetz ausreichend
würde um solche zustände jedenfalls zu
verhindern
wirtschaftsminister altmaier von der cdu
hatte zwar grundsätzlich einem
lieferketten gesetz zugestimmt doch
seine partei wehrt sich das unternehmen
strafen zahlen müssen wenn ihre
zulieferer lohndumping betreiben oder
menschenrechte verletzen
natürlich ist es mir als
wirtschaftsminister auch wichtig dass
die deutsche wirtschaft am ende stärker
nicht schwächer da steht
während hierzulande der streit um das
neue gesetz weiter geht wird in spanien
weiter geerntet und einer blonden kämpft
mit der trauer um den toten bruder
ich fühle mich so schuldig weil ich
diejenige war die ihm geholfen hat
hierher zu kommen
[Musik]
ich kann nachts nicht schlafen ich finde
einfach keine ruhe
ich kann es einfach nicht glauben dass
ich ihn hier her geholt habe damit er
dann hier stirbt
[Musik]